okay it's another slow Sunday every day
is like sounds channeling Morrissey yeah
everyday Sunday since the end of the
world every day is silent and gray I
wish not for that's too sunny yeah I
think it rained earlier yeah it looks
kind of wet out there when I went out
this morning we got a lot of work done
on the cookbook well no we didn't get a
lot well for the out wait wait for yeah
we got like the outline know what's what
we're gonna put on it and I typed down a
list of like all the sections and like
what was going in each section and [ __ ]
I still haven't started the layout yet
because I was gonna start it today but
then I got a I have to do a um an album
cover yeah that's gonna take several
days to do yeah so I have to do that
first probably yeah and to my buddy Jay
ear he sent me that recipe for tortillas
how to make corn tortillas yeah and
turns out we we saw that masa that masa
that you use yes there's a bunch of it
there was a bunch of a bunch of it here
at at our local Publix I'm gonna buy
some of that and see how close it is
just a standard corn flour because I'm
not sure they could get that in Europe
but I think it's just corn flour
although most people like when we talked
about it yesterday on the side track
show like most people that were
Europeans are were in other countries
said you could pretty easily get pretty
much anything that's Mexican though true
and that's kind of a specialty but like
I said you know they do have you know
particularly in bigger cities in Europe
and stuff they do have like you know
ethnic markets if you wanna call him
that and like I said you can always
order stuff online I don't even know we
had that we were looking for regular
flour flour bread flour everybody's
making bread in their hands now because
all the [ __ ] flour was gone and there
was that battle and there was that bag
of white and yellow damn a corn masa
yeah tortillas yeah after that it was
cheap too no sis that's it right there
yeah should have got some I was there
yeah not gonna make get it but we were
doing other things at the time
yeah we needed booze yeah so I need to
actually learn to make some myself so I
could give advice on it I want to see
how close it is the cornflour yeah
because I mean we came up with so many
recipes and it was like this book is
easily gonna be 200 pages beautifully
more but the thing about it is that we
wanted to put everything in there that
like that we had made before so like we
know it's good but even just with those
parameters we still came up with like a
[ __ ] ton of yeah like like a hundred
something recipes I think we came yeah
and there's only a couple things that
I've never made on that recipe stuff
you're gonna need like I don't really
recall me ever making my own mayonnaise
but I don't think I'll have to make I
don't think I'll have to tell anybody
how to make mayonnaise probably not and
I've made jelly before like good jelly
right that's pretty easy when we were
talking about like comments and various
things like that yeah but I mean you
know [ __ ] like that's easy to make yeah
and you know we're still trying to
decide like what exactly we're gonna put
in there some things might be thrown out
we'll see yeah but I mean we do have
like a pretty good like outline and I
have an idea of how I'm gonna lay it out
and stuff but like I said I got you
today I got an album cover
evidently England and Germany do have
American barbecue sauce
although somebody from England said that
[ __ ] barbecue sauce was like
something that you threw on the ground
and ate yeah yeah that's why I don't
trust foreign [ __ ] well it might not be
exactly the same it's like what I was
over there and like I said this was a
while back they had just started selling
like american-style bagels and like
american-style Donuts and those were
pretty good although I might have told
this story before but like my ex
mother-in-law bought the bagels and she
didn't like no like you know because
they hadn't seen them before and she
just ate him right out of the bag like
she didn't tell summer I was like that's
ghetto so I was like you can't do that
with those you can do that with some
some of the real heavy Yiddish will have
a good yeah
like you can just put cream cheese or
whatever on them and eat them but this
lender's bagels which is what I think
these were which is you know the kind
that you just buy at the grocery store
that it you gotta tell us that that's a
civilian bagel they're two they're too
chewy to like what do you toast them
they're actually quite delightful Gatos
I'm gonna put bustard butter and you
gotta put cream Jaisal I only just put
cream cheese and just ham egg and cheese
on it's really good too well yeah I was
I make a breakfast Sam other place to
make breakfast sandwiches if you want to
get redneck with it he's like scrambled
egg cheddar cheese and a sausage patty
with hot sauce and jelly great jelly
you're gonna do we're gonna do like a
whole breakfast sandwich that's how
redneck he's actually like some Waffle
House and what's great is like none of
that [ __ ] is kosher and front cab agels
a Jewish man I bet you them Jewish
people are [ __ ] ahead and [ __ ] skin
crawls when they see it you know the
kosher did they serve I'm just like what
they're eating that damn sausage patty
on it I don't know if anybody gets to
you uptight of it when I was in Israel
man out when I was in Israel we walked
into a Pizza Hut they [ __ ] looked at
us like we were [ __ ] crazy when we
were everything we ordered like no we
don't we can't serve that to you you
know like you couldn't have pepperoni oh
good a pepperoni and then we're like
well do you have any beef and they were
like like any kind of beef from beef and
cheese type toppings you can't put beef
on top of cheese that's that's not
kosher and I said yeah why is that you
know well that's like cooking a mother
in it so others child in its own and
milk and I was like what like I said I
don't know like in the US I don't think
there's any there's no I'm sure there's
probably some that are like super
Orthodox if she wanted cheese on pizza
in any kind of meat on it had to be
shrimp so that's what we had well that's
good too
yeah the same as damn pepperoni this was
Pizza Hut you know what I am NOT eats a
hut it like I'll eat pepperoni but it's
kind of way down there on my list of
what's probably because it gives me
heartburn too I would rather have
honestly but one of my favorite pizzas
growing up when I was a little kid like
before we even had like dominos and all
that [ __ ] where I grew up we had like a
local pizzeria called Pantheon I don't
know if it's still there or not but it
was just like a little bitty place and
we would get these gigantic pieces
we always got hamburger and onion and
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] delicious yeah it
was like this big giant and it was like
hand-tossed and everything was like
really really good yeah I'll put some
I'll put a couple recipes in there for
good [ __ ] barbecue so I was like like
Jack Daniels barbecue sauce yes I'm with
whiskey in it with [ __ ] something has
flavor well cuz like I said there's lots
of different kinds some people like it
sweeter or something oh I get more so
hot so he's like so I'll put there I'll
put a couple recipes for that in there
and if you think if you guys had real
barbecues Brazilians hated barbecue
sauce they [ __ ] hated it but they
didn't know how to eat it
ya thought was a substitute for ketchup
and that's not what it is
no it's it has different you have to
cook it yeah you put it on meat and then
cook it yeah it turns into like a glaze
yeah
sticky yeah you can't like go eat in a
barbecue restaurant like and be like on
a date or a oh yeah we're gonna put a
whole bunch of a classic [ __ ] white
trash southern food in there you guys
gonna like that [ __ ] yeah I came up with
a whole bunch of you don't like my
grandma used to make
yeah that's in there all that kind of
stuff we're gonna do that if I can
remember how she made I think I remember
that guy peas and ham fried okra grits
and red eyes grits and red I agree yeah
soda grits yeah we've we have that for
breakfast loaded Cajun grits you know
you will get fat on this [ __ ] well yeah
if you eat it regularly that's right I'm
gonna make comments in there why don't
you teach out a minute it is not
something that you want to live on you
will be like most of the [ __ ] cuz
you're diabeetus our parents as
generations from the south they're fat
diabetes you know stunted growth to show
them this is a once in a once a weekend
oh yes maybe yeah you don't want to yeah
southerners kind of because of the diet
you know the impact of the civil war and
basically generations of [ __ ] ethnic
cleansing so I can southern there's a
kind of short squat kind of [ __ ]
heavyset people that's that's there they
tend to
I made they don't live long because what
they were eating yeah yeah but it's it's
gotten better in our it has yeah because
I think people have expanded you know
their diets got better yeah and the
diets have gotten better as well and
people are more like aware of how bad
that [ __ ] is for you it's like you still
eat it but not every day yeah my parents
and grandparents generation thought it
was good for you they actually I can put
pork grease in the damn baby bottle yeah
to make them more healthy so no one no
one no one of my dad's getting [ __ ]
quadruple bypasses oh yeah first they
were vapor trying to like bacon grease
yeah if you weren't eating like seconds
and thirds of like every meal they
thought there was something the matter
with you they wanted you to be like
really big and like yeah and there was
like some weird [ __ ] tropes from that
era you know I mean it was you know like
all you know the Beverly Hillbillies and
[ __ ] southerners where they had like
you know Ellie Mae Clampett and [ __ ]
Daisy Duke you know the cute southern
girls southerners were cute they're very
cute they were cute up until they were
about 18 or 19
yeah yeah very cute till they get old
enough to get fat and pregnant
started falling out yes sweetie and
[ __ ] [ __ ] another [ __ ] sugar that's
19 it was it was stuff that tasted good
and it was cheap you eat a lot of it
banana moon pies and [ __ ] [ __ ] Little
Debbie cakes like everything made out is
it for real sweet tea is like sweet
rocket I can't drink it either and I
like sweet [ __ ] but I say it's too sweet
it's like drinking yeah syrup I could
drink it as a kid but I can't go back
and drink it it's just a [ __ ] yeah it's
God I forgot how much did how much sugar
they put in that yeah it's it kind of
makes you it was third world level sugar
it was like you were living in [ __ ]
Haiti somewhere if I can get that bag of
sugar put the whole thing on a damn
sugar cane plantation yeah it's like you
know just might as well put it all in
there man yeah yeah so uh-oh what did we
watch last night we saw another I'm not
gonna review it for the matinee show
because it's not new enough but we did
see an
another yet another Korean horror movie
yeah that was like set I think it was
set in 1504 I think it said the year 15
for it wasn't a zombie movie it was more
like a monster maybe it was a Korean
King Kong yeah it was kinda like a King
Kong a werewolf II meets Booga sorry oh
yeah it was kind of like that it was bad
actually if you guys have never seen
Pogo sorry man see pulgasari you can see
it for free because it's a it's a North
Korean or Hungarian month like their
version of Godzilla's yeah kim
jeong-hoon directed it no no no Kim Jong
Il yeah directed it Kim Jong was dead
and it's it's like a Godzilla movie
they even captured some Japanese people
to [ __ ] help him make it they were
the people I think some actors that
people that worked on Godzilla they
[ __ ] kidnapped them for yeah and they
like made them made to make the movie
yeah and it's kind of it's pulgasari is
kind of better looking than damn
Godzilla he's kind of cool-looking are
you horns and [ __ ] and [ __ ] he starts
off as a little baby one and he's made
of metal and the more metal he eats he
gets bigger and bigger which is an
analogy for capitalism
yeah capitalism eats everything and then
he goes out of control so let's not have
capital as a matter of fact let's not
even have damn food that's what happened
in North Korea but yeah you don't need
[ __ ] food you'll just get fat yeah
it's single hanuman [ __ ] solving
obesity not having any not even [ __ ]
floozy you know instead of getting the
demand instead of getting a supply to
meet the demand you just get the demand
to meet the limited supply so you just
get rid of the people those are just
excess people can't feed them that's
exactly what they did yeah
they ate each other in Korea
I saw someone [ __ ] like um a little
programmer dude it on YouTube I don't
even know if it's there anymore
comparing Google Earth
photographs from now to maps that were
known of North Korea like in the 60s and
most of the damn towns are gone
now they're gone yeah and like there's
an analysis of why they were they
couldn't feed him and there was just
like they relocated a lot of them and
then they ended up dying and then there
was like cannibalism and [ __ ] going on
because some of the towns the people in
those towns were like mining towns but
the mines closed but it's in some places
they think that they'd people just died
yeah because they couldn't supply they
had something called the arduous March
and it was like a 12 year long strain of
famine and [ __ ] it where like the before
and after from the videos before and
after photos were just amazing
millions of them must have died and just
vanished some of the towns are still
sitting there pristine but they haven't
changed in years this means nobody lives
in them yeah they're like abandoned
weird when you think about it it is
imagine that well yeah they they just
added this this movie to shudder I
forgot to say it was called monstrum mom
strong yeah and it's it wasn't as good
as like Kingdom or like some of the
other ones it's not that like I said
it's not zombies it does have like a
sort of plague ish aspect but it's more
like a Black Plague type of thing but it
then it's like a monster movie um you
know it was pretty good it's the CGI
wasn't fantastic and I had trouble
keeping track of all the characters I'd
really matter I think that [ __ ] kid
from train to Busan was in this one too
yeah maybe that kid is in [ __ ] every
star I guess he must be because he's
been in like the last three Korean
movies I saw Korean it's you know these
Korean movies see that I mean they're
the korean historical genres is really
so far you can tell that it's about
palace intrigue yeah and and so that's
their you know that's their thing so
it's about palace intrigue and then with
young bees with some kind of layered
over it and in this one it's kind of a
monster that looks like a damn Korean or
Chinese dog lion statue it looks like a
foo dog cept he's like super super big
yeah in Korea in China you know the with
the pictures you can tell that the
people who kind of made these pictures
back in the day really were confused
about the
difference between a dog and a lion and
they probably misidentified lions as
dogs and dogs as lions and it was kind
of like the same animal for them because
some of their breeds of dogs when you
look at him kind of like a lion mane
yeah so I don't think they differentiate
between lions and dogs they probably
just called it the same damn thing well
the monsters kind of like that it's kind
of like a dog and a lion yeah like I see
you almost kind of has a werewolf II
type of thing but he's real he's real
real big did she like elephant size or
maybe bigger than that bigger than an
elephant yeah yeah it's bigger than
mightyjoyoung it's probably bad hat it's
probably about 1/3 the size of King Kong
yeah it's big
yeah and it's I thought the thing was
kind of sympathetic you're kind of
rooting for the damn animal the monster
because the monster has been [ __ ] over
yeah and also most of the people's paper
dicks to it most of the people yeah so I
kind of was like I thought they were
gonna do a thing where the monster was
kind of kind of be and that maybe like
being a hero or something that really
they just say just killed it but yeah
that's on shudder cause it was like I
said it's it seems like it's a whole
kind of genre I think it came out in
2018 or 2017 or something like that
that's why I said well I don't really
want to do it for the matinee show
because it's you know the acting good
all the [ __ ] fight choreography the
costumes the sets it all looked really
good the only thing that was kind of
weak was the CG or the marks on the
monster yeah it looked okay it was just
okay yeah it was okay it was it was
video I mean it wasn't as bad as say
like you know saw sci-fi channels
[ __ ] CG right yeah it was better than
that but it wasn't as good as you know a
top top notch CG I would think it would
have been better had they not shown it
much and and it had been you know I mean
practical effects yeah and just forced
perspective you know maybe somebody in a
costume or something I think it would've
been a little bit better cuz it really
didn't look like it was there not to me
yeah yeah that's true it's in it I kind
of like moved around too fast
yeah it looked around too fast for it's
it's supposed size yeah it didn't give
you the impression that it was massive
well a lot of CGI has done
like even really expensive CGI they
borrowed like elements of it's like a
cross a tween alien and King Kong ji is
that yeah it had elements of both except
you know set in sixteenth floor area so
wasn't it bad yeah is okay it wasn't as
good like I said it wasn't as good as
Kingdom or that other Korean Zombie
movies yeah it was set around the same
time period that I can't broker the name
I'm right now yeah give it bonus points
though what for it was a unique monster
it wasn't a ripoff it looked like a
Chinese or a Korean monster yeah it
really it really did it did fit the the
motif yeah although they hinted that
they got it from the Far West
yeah hinted that they did but it was
like in a menagerie and yeah it was
called monstrum yeah that's what they
called it like it was something from the
West but it had like it was weird
because it had like more than any of the
other similar ones we've seen lately it
had like more comedic elements yeah they
did like kind of it wasn't a comedy but
it did have like some funny you know it
may have been although it I can't say
that I said it looked like you said it
looked a little bit like a werewolf in a
way yeah but it doesn't but it wasn't a
lycanthropy it didn't change
wasn't it I can throw yeah he was just
like a month just way it was it was
something they pulled out of their ass
but it did look Chinese or Korean yeah
they should have said that they should
have said they got it from China yeah
that's what they should have said though
they got it from the Far West what
America yeah it's Bigfoot
it's rainy it's a windy it would have
been cooler if it had just been [ __ ]
Bigfoot Sasquatch walks on all fours
yeah yeah so we watched that and then we
were also we were on shudder still and
then I've been trying to like watch all
the Joe Bob last drive-in movies but
he's got like a whole bunch of them up
now and it's like I haven't so I decided
to watch blood harvest last night which
of you and I had never seen it before it
came out in 1987 and apparently this was
a movie that Tiny Tim
yeah if you guys don't know who Tiny Tim
is he was like probably late 60s early
70s in Salinas heyday he was super weird
he's like an informants artist he did
like tiptoe through the tulips oh it was
famous song and he was like on [ __ ]
Johnny Carson and [ __ ] like that he look
like the penguin from Batman - that's
what he really looked like without the K
I'm costumer the penguin from yeah and
Tim Burton's penguin not quite as fat
but yeah a bigger version of with that
nose and everything and he kind of acted
like that kinda yeah he creepy with the
same kind of teeth and [ __ ] yeah as a
weird dude he was a very well um my dad
told me about him when I was a kid he
said you know like I'd never heard of
the dude he goes yeah there was this guy
named tiny - told ruder - yeah and he
was like that weird like false and I
couldn't believe it I thought he was
kind of bullshitting me this like not
that this is when I was like 13 he's
telling me that how'd that turn out that
was real yeah and you had a moment like
you know in the late 60s early 70s he
was actually really famous and guys from
my dad's generation thought it was real
that that's what he really was and I
think he was kind of like that but I
think it was also partly a tact I think
he was like any Kaufman where he was
trolling yeah I think for real he was a
weird dude but I mean he was very into
like vaudevillian type of stuff and like
he was you know but they it was cool
because they showed blood harvest and
then they had like um you know Jim Bob
coming in and like talking about it and
they actually had a guy on there who had
written a biography of Tiny Tim and that
was really interesting and then they had
another guy that had like that had
produced some of his albums or something
like later on in his life again I guess
in knew him and knew him and like talked
about him stuff so that was that was
kind of interesting to the movie I have
to say I was expecting because check it
out it was directed by Bill romaine and
it's who was the same guy that directed
and was in the giant spider invasion
which if you guys like we've seen it
like a whole bunch of times because they
did it on the MST and that was one of
that was one of my favorite episodes cuz
that movie is so terrible and I don't
know if I ever told a story my dad took
me to see that in the [ __ ] theaters I
asked to see it when I was a little kid
how old would I have been
I mean Giants what year was that um 70
75 75 said I've been six years old I
think it was 75 that [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] scared the [ __ ] out of me is a
little kill the damn tranche listen the
guys getting eaten by the spiders and
the girl drank the damn spiderweb out of
the blood that whole [ __ ] thing my
dad was laughed at the whole thing is
[ __ ]
oh yeah it's a ridiculous [ __ ] you don't
agree but if I can scared the [ __ ] out
of me I had nightmares for [ __ ] weeks
but it's funny like like you said you're
like isn't that that same house from
from it was the same house and I'm going
like yeah that is recognizing yeah and
directors house it's the directors out
well it's the shooting ranch that's we
call it apparently likes they shot a
whole bunch of movies there and I guess
like the crew would stay there and shits
in [ __ ] Wisconsin yeah I guess yeah
he was trying to you know what else to
do he was trying to make his own studio
in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere in
Wisconsin and he did make a [ __ ] ton of
movies and people are still talking
about giant spider vision in particular
[ __ ] we just saw the RiffTrax live I
think last year that's one of my
favorite episodes of MST because just
it's it's golden I mean all the [ __ ]
there's real tarantulas in it but like
the giant spider of which there is only
one is clearly a Volkswagen Beetle with
fur on it yeah legs and legs like on
this is not as bad as you think it is
though when you understand the story
behind the [ __ ] movie and it did kind
of have some interesting characters and
[ __ ] interesting see the characters
are like all super sleazy yeah we're the
sleazy Appalachian dude trying to move
on his [ __ ] steps sister-in-law
wasn't his noses no it was his
stepdaughter or sister and it was his
sister-in-law maybe it was his sister
that was like his wife's yeah this
wife's youngest sister and that they're
all in the Damned and she's not a
seventeen yeah everybody's like scantily
clad and they look like scantily clad
hillbillies and [ __ ] you don't mean it's
it was it's like totally skeevy as [ __ ]
but you know it has a certain charm to
it kind of in a way that makes you need
to take a shower
what in another era whatever you know is
from another era in another era about it
then you're like what the [ __ ] what am I
favorite MST riffs was when somebody
gets eaten by the spider
yeah the bit the giant spider and servo
says does it matter that the spider
stuffed him up his butt my dad mentioned
the same damn thing when I was watching
it as a little kid he's like that's its
mouth yes it's clearly but okay yeah
he's eating people through the head how
inhale and it [ __ ] his first line in
the movie is [ __ ] sheep and then
they're talking deep deep science
alright like they're in a scientific
laboratory it's obviously the high
school [ __ ] science lab yeah it's
like the biology with the biology they
have the [ __ ] stupid beakers set up
everywhere like just they're talking
about meteors coming in from black holes
and other I don't know how a black hole
had anything the earth guy hit with a
black hole and it Unleashed spiders from
another dimension yeah that's like geo
that came in geodes motorcyclists
remember that the kind of dirtbike it
first it did all kinda nervous guys
hiding the fact that all those cows were
getting eaten and he was trying to sell
the meat to like this yeah but even
that's another movie this movie is shot
in the same [ __ ] place it's the same
house the same house I was like hey
that's Giants paper but I must say it's
much better I tell you what next - I
mean blood harvest okay it's not a great
movie but a scene next to giant spider
invasion
it looks like [ __ ] Godfather - it's
like Citizen Kane next yeah that's what
I'm saying it looks like a [ __ ]
masterpiece next to that so like Empire
Strikes Back yes it's totally passable I
was like surprised I was thinking it was
gonna be like really really shitty and
like I was just watching kids of Joe Bob
and I was like Tiny Tim is that it was
that me up he's like playing this creepy
clown doesn't yeah yeah and he was
actually pretty good in it I mean
because he's a creepy dude lots of boobs
yeah there's so many tips yeah yeah yeah
lots of Bush everything in India tell
you what full-frontal yeah
Joe Bob talks about it yeah well because
he does the thing is he 14 breasts our
media
every time they see it and it's a and
the girls are all the girls are all cute
in it yeah yeah I was surprised that
he's trying to dicen it one you know how
to make money he's just trying to get
people to watch the damn movie yeah and
you know he started a cute girl I don't
know how her girl she's probably bought
twenty five twenty it's clear yeah
not really girl I just seen it to me
they're all girls have men or girls knew
[Laughter]
I was coming right but yeah it was
totally worth watching you slasher movie
you know of course of course you can
guess who the killer was like almost in
the first ten minutes it didn't matter
but that's okay it was it was still fun
to watch I'd say that put it up there
with me with like faun house yeah and I
liked fun house I did too we did a
review on it a little while back like I
have that on blu-ray Dona yeah yeah yeah
we do cuz we reviewed it oh yeah so if
you have shudder like I said I'm sure I
was talking talking to UM one of our
patrons on patreon Gianna or Anjana I
don't know if I'm pronouncing it right
but she's been watching all the all the
Jo Bob last drive-ins on shutter too but
it's hard to keep up with them cuz like
I said now used to be he would just do
them on holidays like you would just do
like a marathon like on Christmas or
Halloween or whatever now they put one
up every week it looks like so I'm super
Ryan yeah it's cool you know [ __ ]
Netflix did renewed they didn't renew
MST the new one now that they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] man yeah maybe maybe the
shutter will renew it somebody needs to
pick that [ __ ] back up I liked I liked
the new image yeah it's good I think a
lot of the fans were kind of well fans
reactions were kind of mixed on it but
it's different than the original but but
they were all different from the
originator all different I mean they
changed over time yeah like everybody
changed out like at various times and
you know I there's certain eras that I
like the most like probably even though
it was one of the shortest seasons like
I think season 6 and 7 right in there
where my favorites although I like the
sci-fi ones do like with [ __ ] brain
guy I got a feeling I got a feeling
shudder will pick that up
that would be rad if they yeah I mean if
they like if Joe Bob got his [ __ ] back
on there yeah they could do a bestie
they'd have to kind of probably lower
the budget MST oh well that couldn't
been too expensive to make that
and part of the hold like charm of MST
was like how she jacket was like because
they were just like you know making a
parody of like the movies that they were
doing that we're all so cheap
whenever I watch that MST I feel stupid
this [ __ ] because she'll be over there
laughs and I don't get hardly any good I
get maybe like 1/4 of them you really
have to have a vast array of cultural
now I'll be sitting there you know and
when they start singing I bust out
laughing I have a very strong musical
sense of humor yeah like if they start
but you just have to you have you have
to know MST to know what I'm talking
about but they start singing some kind
of famous tune and and it's in relation
to what's happening I almost always
[ __ ] lose it yeah well some of those
yeah some of those are the best [ __ ]
getting little clever stuff and it's not
effective on me really I don't think
it's funny it's real like lowbrow
emotion-based humor I'll [ __ ] laugh
my ass well like I said that was one of
the things that I was liked about it was
that there was kind of something for
everybody there was like kind of like
but like kind of obscure cultural
references there was just like kind of
clever like literary jokes and stuff and
then there was like fart jokes yeah you
know I mean so it's or musical joke so
they kind of had something like at every
tear that you can appreciate you know
what I mean yeah and they have like
really really high rewatch value I mean
some some episodes I think I've watched
probably at least a hundred I think it
has some do you know where how I grew up
in Brazil and the army and stuff the
mics you know they like the British
clever sense of humor yeah um I've had
I've run into British guys who have done
that to me and purpose you know in in in
in person and for a second I think
they're insulting me now and then I have
to [ __ ] go when I must be beating
this dude's ass yeah because it's true
there's a lot you know boomer has a
cultural confines to it you know like is
this dude [ __ ] mocking me should I be
beating this dude's ass right now I
guess he's not really given the signs
that he's [ __ ] with me but he what he
said I couldn't cuz you know you can
kind of like and interpret it and twist
it you know I mean into something like I
said the
I mean know their their whole thing is
like taking the piss it's not serious
that's just yeah taking the piss though
see this is the thing taking the piss
you can only get away with that in in
certain American circles only if you
like grew up with somebody or you or you
know him real well if it's a if it's a
stranger it could be a [ __ ] problem
you know go to the hood and go try to
take a piss watch what happens you
better learn how to dance cuz they gonna
start shooting at you I got videos of it
you know
now the foreigners but between dudes you
know things can be taken the wrong way
we're so sensitive Americans are so
sensitive it depends on what near a
fence a neighborhood it is you know some
of those [ __ ] some of those videos
actually have audio and you see the see
and hear the exchange and you know I'm
gonna leave it at that
alright you done talking for the day
probably yeah are you done yeah I'm
probably done alright I think uh I don't
have anything to do in terms of cook and
everything's [ __ ] done I got do we
have any chicken leftover yeah I got
some chicken left a little bit I don't
think there's no food both of us being
habit I can make something else then
I'll toss something I'll find something
in there there's we have so much [ __ ]
food in the side I don't even know what
to do alright so uh you guys have a good
rest of your weekend
rest of your Sunday and we'll talk to
you again tomorrow